the only people at ashton gate today are
the players
and those getting their vaccine bristol
city played stoke
behind closed doors reopening them to
the fans
could be down to us all having a covet
passport
every seat will be taken the garden will
be full
everybody's in good spirits and they're
doing what they love doing out here
going to football
the avon packet would usually be rammed
on a match day
and while they prep to reopen the
thought of having to check
covid certificates isn't welcome
they expect us to check everybody check
everybody's details the bottom line
we're here to serve beer and to take
money
i'm not an investigator i don't want to
check
excuse me jim have you got your pass
excuse me fred have you got your
certificate you know tracking trace was
bad enough
trips to the theater could also be on
the list of activities
where you have to prove your covid safe
this is not about a vaccine passport it
is about looking at ways
of proving that you're covered secure
whether you've had a test or had the
vaccine clearly no decisions have been
made in that because we have to weigh up
different factors the ethical
considerations and so on but
it may be a way of ensuring that you can
get more people back doing the things
they love and being in fantastic
institutions like this
it's understood the government is
looking at using the nhs app to
potentially store
our covid status in just a couple of
months time the bristol harbor festival
is due to take place here
it normally attracts around a quarter of
a million people
and it could be large-scale events like
this one up and down the country
which will require some sort of covid
certificate
for those attending i've had both my
vaccines
and it'd be nice to feel that you are
safe somewhere especially
and and get those kind of industries
back up and running if you have to do it
you have to do it
so but i can see the kids are going to
download something off the internet same
as they used to to get into
nightclubs and what have you underaged i
think that'll still go on that element
of it
i don't quite like the sound of that um
people may not have access to you know
technology to show that they've got the
vaccine handy
there's also a lot of vaccine hesitancy
around a lot of communities
there are big ethical privacy and legal
concerns
with more than 70 mps and campaign
groups against
the idea i think this is a really
really troubling idea it's unnecessary
we've got a fantastic vaccination
program we should be coming out of
this crisis it's unworkable and it's
unbritish
we're not a nation that lives unlicensed
we're not a nation that carries
id cards many of us will enjoy
regained freedoms this easter weekend
getting them all back
by the summer could mean we have to
carry a new type of passport
dan whitehead sky news in bristol